you're in business tough shot no good
here comes Kadeem Allen up to Kevin Knox
he's got enough to quick starts in his
games and continues to do so here that's
his second field goal
turned on coaches appreciation day this
is a move that any coach would love back
after this it is absolutely spectacular
done some major upgrades slightly Kevin
Knox nice rip move couldn't finish did
on the second attempt Kevin Knox looking
very aggressive saw Fred vanvleet and
Kyle Lowry playing at the same time
right he needs to go to the rim which he
did and then this will come that's his
first field goal Dan he's one for five
telling you no bells good defendant no
bells a tough kid but no Val gets abused
they gotten to the free-throw line six
times in this game double-digit free
throws should be the thing shoot off of
that and he'll be spot
well Kevin Knox drills the three to
complement Barrett just a guy didn't
really have a prominent role no RJ Perry
hits another three ball handing in your
retirement papers to the league office
but it's close you at least know where
they are nice move by Barrett he seems
to be in a nice offensive flow right now
dam posin foul line gets comfortable
then when you get comfortable you do
things like that Bart he certainly has
embraced the spotlight of being in New
York and being their top first-round
pick number to take him among the top
five guys to shoot the ball at the end
of the game he was a clutch guy in the
tournament against Ohio State against
UNC Wilmington
I'd take him to make some shots to eat
not bad once the regular season starts
regardless of the Miss New York with a
twink I love his don't want to be a
player no more that's one of my favorite
jams you're not a player you just crush
a lot I just crush the lodgement Muncie
sneezes South Florida resident now you
know I think dockage hit the nail on the
head they've got some young guys that
they're trying to develop and they're
gonna try to get into the mix in 2021
which Kauai has an option for that year
now you're at 11 points in the game hit
one three now here at 40 get it
offensive rebound now you're at 16
get a steal in a layup tired eight I
mean you don't have to make a ton of
shine air it out top nice in and out
dribble with the offhand RJ parrot
little sauce on that one he's got 21
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
bleacher report maker that you subscribe
for some more video content